Now I'm talking about the harsh realities
of the
assemblies and how the de Bruijn graphs
faces these realities.
During the course of the discussion,
we have made some ridiculous unrealistic
assumptions.
Like, we assume that we have perfect
coverage of the genome by reads.
That means at each position on the genome,
we have a read generated at
that position.
Secondly, we assume that reads are
error-free.
Thirdly, we assume that multiplicities of
k-mers are known.
And also we assume that the distance between
reads within read-pairs were
known exactly.
But in reality, these
assumptions do not hold.
We don't have
perfect coverage of genome by reads.
Reads are error-prone.
The multiplicity of k-mers are not known,
either.
The distance between reads, within
read-pairs, are inexact.
And there are many other problems.
But let's go to the first unrealistic
assumption, perfect coverage.
Here we have the genome on the top, and
here are the four reads.
Clearly that we don't have the perfect
coverage in this case,
and it violates the key assumption of the de
Bruijn graph.
So, what we can do is to break the reads
into shorter k-mers.
And after this operation,
the key assumption of the de Bruijn graph
holds.
What is next?
About the erroneous reads.
This is an erroneous reads.
By breaking
an erroneous read into a series of k-mers, we
also generate
false k-mers.
And how these
false k-mers
appear in the graph.
Well, if k-mers were exact, then for any
region of the genome, the de Bruijn
graph would look like this.
But when we introduce incorrect k-mers into
the graph, we create bubble.
Imagine, for an assembly data set usually
we have
millions of incorrect k-mers, and they form
a lot of
bubbles.
So the challenge here is to find
out how the genome traverses this graph,
(depicting by the color line).
Researchers have developed algorithms for.
removing these bubbles and simplify the
graph.
But should the graph look very simple
after this step?
Well, this is the graph of a bacteria genome
after simplification.
And now, it is time to ask and answer the
question, who are these people?
Pavel, are you still here?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Can you answer the question?
>> So, these people.
are not criminals.
These are scientists and entrepreneurs who
made their
genomes have been available a few years ago and
started the
personalized genomics revolution.
And today this personalized genomic
sequencing efforts are in full
bloom, and we will soon expand sequencing
to millions of individuals.
At the same time.
there are efforts to sequence thousands of
genomes and we
will soon have nearly over a million
genomes, for example, sequenced.
Simultaneously, with this there are
enormous effort to sequence cancer
genomes and understand what changes in the
genome lead to cancer.
And at the heart of this,
genomic revolution are by
young
mathematicians like Son who has been
wroking for two
decades now to develop new algorithmic
ideas for genome sequencing.
You may ask, well why in the world we
started by making some
ridiculous assumptions that Son had to
address
in the last segment of this presentation.
So what's a good reason for this?
Without this assumption, we wouldn't be
able to present the main
ideas of existent genome sequencing
algorithms.
And there's actually a common saying in
bioinformatics, to
simplify the problem to the point that it
becomes ridiculous,
solve this problem, which means to develop
the key idea for solving a ridiculous
problem.
And then overcome some ridiculous
assumptions.
Something that Son described in the last
segment.